>>Teacher: But then it's
also saves more naps.
[ laughter ]
>>Mark: If we're learning at our
highest potential as teachers,
it's only going to serve our students.
When we learn, they learn.
We're a community of learners.
>>Pauline: Because we do teacher lab, we
are constantly being driven by a desire
to grow together, to collaborate, to
communicate, and to be self-reflective.
>>Amy: They're actually
teaching me things sometimes.
Let's me know you're really engaged.
>>Valerie: I want you to call me over.
I'll take a look at your work.
>>Mark: When teachers enhance their
craft and improve their skills,
then students will improve their level
of learning and academic achievement.
So teacher labs are a way we formally
get teachers together to collaborate.
>>Thank you all for being here.
>>Teachers come together,
cross discipline.
It's about a three hour
session around one focus area.
>>This morning, we're focusing
on student engagement,
specifically student talk.
>>Pauline: These kids
have got to be engaged
in meaningful discourse with each other.
>>Mark: It's facilitated by
our instructional specialist.
She walks them through a
protocol that's very defined,
with the ultimate purpose
of teacher growth.
>>Pauline: Somebody volunteers
to be a host teacher.
>>Valerie: Let's think
about how we get there.
>>Pauline: Valerie's an
eighth grade math teacher,
and she wants to get some feedback
to improve how students
communicate when problem solving.
>>Valerie: My biggest goal
for the year is trying to get
that collaborative work, that
collaborative problem solving--
>>We start off by identifying what
student engagement looks like,
both from the student side
and from the teacher side.
>>Mark: Hopefully, we hear kids
asking each other questions.
>>Teacher: That asking for help,
without having negative
feelings towards themselves
or that they think their
peers are looking
at them differently,
because they didn't know.
>>Pauline: After the discussion,
the host teacher speaks to the group
about what the lesson
is going to be about.
>>Valerie: So I've given you
handouts that the kids will get.
>>I talked about the
goals of the lesson,
what I wanted teachers
to look for and observe.
>>Focus in on how they interact
with the task, how engaged they are.
Hopefully they'll be able to justify
why the correct ways are correct.
>>Amy: By setting the stage,
it kind of gets us thinking.
Teacher lab is not just for the host.
It is really for every
teacher that attends.
>>Valerie: Estimates for
the population of Brazil.
>>Pauline: We go to the
host teacher's room.
They teach the lesson, and as
observers, we will be making notes.
>>Valerie: Today, we're going
to look at population change.
I want to start off with a video.
>>We talked about population growth.
It's intriguing to students
and something
that has some real implications.
>>How could governments estimate
year to year population changes,
without making a complete census?
>>It led into the math very nicely.
>>Student: One nine eight
point seven eight.
>>Amy: I was looking for key words like,
"Let me show you," or
"How can I help you?"
or "Can you explain this better?"
>>Student: What do you add?
What do you add?
Oh, you rounded out to
two point oh seven.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Valerie: After the teachers
observe the lesson, we come back
and Pauline facilitates
in the post discussion,
asking the host teacher
to just quietly listen.
>>Pauline: The process is,
we all go around and share
with Valerie what we noticed.
>>It's very celebratory.
The first thing that teachers
report back on are the wonderful,
amazing things that they saw.
>>Teacher: I noticed a lot of math
vocabulary when I heard them speaking.
>>Amy: There were mistakes,
but they talked about them,
and I don't think they ever
said, "You were wrong."
>>Pauline: So let's move
on to questions.
>>Then they ask wonderings.
>>Mark: I wondered, how do we get
kids to that level to say, "Oh, Eli,
we haven't heard from
you in a little bit.
What are you thinking?"
>>Amy: The red light strategy, I
was just curious what that was.
>>Pauline: The host teacher
makes notes on all the questions
that everybody had, and
then they can respond.
>>Valerie: We have a
lot of great questions.
The red light strategy is a strategy
I got from a training over the summer.
>>Pauline: Everybody walks
away with some new knowledge,
some new gained perspective.
>>He made a student engagement
teacher lab page.
Just identify a strategy or an
action that you want to take back
to your classroom and employ.
>>Valerie: My big takeaway was that
students need support learning how
to justify their answers,
explain their solutions.
>>Student: It doesn't
show you how it works.
>>Valerie: And they need
some examples for that.
>>Read the solution.
Think about if you have any
questions before you get started.
>>Pauline: We're really asking teachers
to step outside of their comfort zone.
We are creatures that
live behind closed doors.
>>Valerie: Record those estimates.
>>Pauline: Normally, nobody
ever comes in and sees it.
>>Student: What did you get
for the change of birth?
>>Pauline: To experience being
in somebody else's classroom,
it's really powerful.
>>What I love about teacher labs
is, we've all got something from it.
>>I think that speaks volumes
to the work that you do
in your classrooms, so
thank you so much.